uh it's intriguing because he didn't
appear on the injury report at all this
year peter with a knee or anything else
other than a rest day from time to time
so they better be careful how much they
pump up the legend of tom brady by
talking about him playing with a bad
knee or some people with the bucks are
going to have to make an involuntary
contribution to the charity of the nfl's
choice
yeah i mean look you
i didn't see him the whole year looked
like anything was wrong with his knee i
was taken by surprise when when i heard
that but
you know i and look i don't know what it
is i i don't have any idea but i do
think
that at age 43
it's probably uh it's probably
i i don't i don't even want to say
intelligent to get clean up surgery if
anything at all is wrong
but
i i would guess that this has been
you know uh over the years this has kind
of been a brewing situation but i will
say
about just his health one of the
interesting things looking back on a
year ago and it was i guess 13 months
ago when he played his last game for the
for the patriots
and the questions there about his arm
strength
and
i'll tell you his arm strength was
really very good this year all the way
through the super bowl one of the
interesting things that uh i talked to
clyde christensen yesterday the
quarterback coach and he was talking
about same thing that byron leftwich
told me you know
it's just too bad we don't have four or
five more games you know because of how
well we're playing right now and we just
started playing really really well
and i'm not sure that many of their
players would agree it's a shame that we
don't have four or five more games i
think at the end of a 20-game season or
21 you've had enough
yeah and it was from seven and five to
eight no they really did hit their
stride after their bye week after they
lost to the kansas city chiefs had two
weeks for the next game and they went
from there
um
the the the tom brady acquisition in
hindsight one of the great moves that
any team has made in any off-season the
buccaneers knew what they had
they knew what they wanted and they went
and got it here's bruce aryan speaking
to you earlier this week on brady
ultimately being the missing piece to
the puzzle for the buccaneers
i told us hey dude remember our first
conversation
he said vividly
so we're going to uconn we'll win the
super bowl
did you really know
i knew he was the missing piece
because we were so talented last year
and what yeah
secondary coming on
i knew i knew it could be
really really good defensively and all
we needed was a leader
yeah
and i loved jameis but famous wasn't he
wasn't the guy
the big concern about jameis came in
december i remember aryans talking about
that last year december is when the
foundation is laid for a championship
run that's when the great quarterbacks
step up that's when james stepped off
that's when jameis disintegrated that's
when jameis finished his run to 30
interceptions and aryans knew at that
point we need better than this if we're
going to compete for a championship so
out goes jameis for a team that was
seven and seven going into the final two
games of the year in comes brady on a
team that was seven and five going into
the final four what happens december
rolls around and off they go peter
what was so interesting about the
pursuit of tom brady is that uh
i've come to believe now it's more that
more of uh who did tom brady want
you know obviously i believe he was
interested in the indianapolis colts
that interest was not
uh reciprocated
i believe the los angeles chargers were
interested in him i don't think he
wanted to
to do to live out there because of his
family situation
um
and then i think the other thing that
was all will always be sort of this kind
of hazy mystery hanging over it mike
is
how serious was the new orleans saints
uh interest how serious would that
interest have been if drew brees
actually had walked away because i
believe at the end of last year that
organization believed that drew brees
was going to walk away after 2019
and then he had time to think about it
and he said no i'm gonna i'm gonna stay
but what so what basically happened
uh i think is that
that story never really had a chance to
happen because brees came back now would
it have happened i don't know but i do
think that sean uh sean payton
being the quarterback maven that he is
would definitely have at least kicked
the tires on that one mike
and the 49ers the other team that
admitted to taking a look at tom brady
decided to keep jimmy garoppolo over tom
brady not that the 49ers would have
gotten back to the super bowl and won it
if brady had gone there they were
besieged by injuries this year but if
brady had gone to the 49ers the
buccaneers aren't winning the super bowl
this year and it quite possibly would
have been a chief's repeat peter so it
just shows you what one domino can do as
we stand on the brink
of so many potential dominoes falling
this offseason already the matthew
stafford for jared goff trade that we
know about desean watson russell wilson
etc it it really makes you wonder who
out there has a vision like the one that
bruce arians had last year and there's a
missing piece that that coach or that gm
wants
and they'll be the team we're talking
about a year from now that made it work
mike i i want to keep an eye on the
carolina panthers
um i think that
although they love uh teddy bridgewater
is a guy
he had a c or c plus season and i think
the panthers look at that and think they
need better at quarterback now
will they get
will they
be able to do better at quarterback they
certainly sniffed around significantly
on matthew stafford
so i don't think they're out of uh the
equation here
uh to to change quarterbacks
and even if they don't i do think
they're going to look into it the one
other team that that i think is
interesting right now and interesting
going forward
is washington because
i think emotionally they feel like
they're tied to alex smith and you saw
they signed taylor heineke for two years
this week which i think was a really
smart decision on their part
but the question is
they have a defense that's ready to win
now they have to look at their own
organization their own team and say
do we think that alex smith is good
enough to play deep in the playoffs the
emotional story is one thing but is his
ability good enough to play deep in the
playoffs now
they may decide that it is but i'm going
to be watching washington as well
you caught my attention earlier when you
talked about the desire on the part of
some buccaneers to continue the season
even though they're at the top of the
mountain they planted the flag they
grabbed the trophy they threw it from
one boat to another here's byron
leftwich explaining to you his wish that
the season actually had gone on four
games longer
i just felt confident in you know what
we what we had as a game plan who we are
and what we become as a team
it was really about the moral confidence
in the team on where we i've been around
a lot of good football teams
and where we've been at the past two
three four weeks we've been getting
better every week you know and this the
tough part for us we will be so much
better a month from now we was kind of
wishing that we could have four more
games to play
just to just keep rapping and just keep
you know seeing how far we can take this
thing
that's a scary thought
regarding where they may be
next year you know they did struggle at
times they did limp into their bye week
they come out of the gates uh
hot they come out of the gates ready
they get the saints maybe early in the
season and get a chance to show that
last year's sweep in the regular season
was kind of a fluke thing and they're
ready now of course the saints are going
to be a very different team peter i yeah
it's amazing to think this team didn't
win its division and i look at the nfc
south right now and i look at where the
bucks are and i look at these other
three teams and
there's the possibility there's going to
be a gap there next year
what was really interesting in my
conversations with a bunch of tampa bay
people this week
okay so mike remember
they lost to the saints 38 to three at
home
uh
this year and one of the things about
that game that i've asked four or five
people
what was brady like
the day of that you know the night of
that game and and the next day and clyde
christensen the quarterback coach said
he showed up the next day
uh no
real sadness no mourning no anything
other than
we're good enough
we are good enough we just have to play
better and mike i want you to consider a
couple of things when people say well
how do you say that after a 38-3 game
consider a couple of things
the first time that tom brady
got into a huddle
with his offensive teammates
was 28 days before the start of the
regular season
okay
the first time he had an offense defense
practice
against the buccaneers in full pads okay
the first time
as blaine gabbard told me
we had our practice on august 14th which
was the first time
which should have been our practice on
may 14th
you know three months ago but we never
had an off season program
so that's why
the buccaneers were really inconsistent
that's why brady looks so bad on that
two minute drill at chicago that's why
he looks so shaky against the giants on
monday night football and that's i mean
they just were not very good
and i had somebody tell me that they
never had a full-flung two-minute drill
you know live two-minute drill
they had practiced plays in a two-minute
drill but never had a live two-minute
drill before that game against chicago
which seems absurd but that's the kind
of year it was
and that's why byron leftwich says hey
we're just getting good right now it's
me to be unbelievable if we could play
four more weeks
and that success they had coming out of
the by down the stretch in the regular
season into the playoffs it built more
and more and more confidence here's
aryans talking to you about the
confidence the team had going into a
game the super bowl that they were
picked to lose
i knew we were going to win this game
wow how did you know
the way we practice the way we've been
playing i mean people don't give us
credit man our defense is
good and
we turned it over i mean
we went up and kicked
out of green bay
and
i i knew
todd would have a great plan
after we played him the first time we
learned our lesson
and he had a great plan they were not
getting that in the end zone he set out
there and rogers in the red zone and put
up my
how long did you talk to aryans after
the game what was the gap because i
think he had a chance
to hydrate a bit
between the end of the game and the time
he talked to you
i'll tell you what was absolutely crazy
about that
i asked aryans uh you know before the
game saturday or sunday i forget i sent
him a text and i said hey weird year and
everything i'm really gonna need you
after this game and he sent me back a
thumbs up emoji
and a whiskey glass emoji
you know with brown liquid in the glass
and so but anyway no i
here's what was really strange about the
game after the game i said oh my god i
got i got to try to get todd bowles
i mean that defense was just incredible
i got to try to get bowls
so
i got bowls for like
five minutes and i was just getting
ready to ask him another question and i
looked down and there's aryans calling
me so hey todd congratulations
uh you know have a good time whatever
and i clicked over to aryans right then
and so that was about an hour after the
game i would say maybe
hour hour ten but clearly they had
already had the on-field celebration and
everything and he was in his office at
the stadium when i talked to him but i'm
assuming he had a styrofoam cup with
brown liquid but i don't know
could have been rum and coke because
after all as bruce aryan says rum and
coke is the drink i drink when i'm not
drinking so uh who knows either way he
deserved it that night won the super
bowl after a lifetime in football
finally at the top of the mountain you
mentioned bowles
bowles talked to you about the defensive
game plan and the motivation the
defensive players had and let's hear uh
from bulls and we'll react a bit on the
other side
both guys are young so the biggest thing
they do is read and look at tv all the
time and nobody picked up and gave us a
chance to win but they were really
pissed off about that and you know
combine that with the things we missed
the first game and messed up i think
they were embarrassed but they learned
how to be professionals about it from
the last time we played them the biggest
thing was they wanted to come out and
fight we had to give them some tools to
fight with do you think all things
considered
this is the best game plan and
performance by a defense that you
choreographed and planned in your
coaching career
uh might be the best one that's worked i
thought i had some great ones that were
[Laughter]
it might be the best one that worked
this
oh that's great that's great and a
genius plan and and part of the problem
for the chiefs was they didn't expect it
they stepped on the rake they went right
into thinking they were going to see the
same defense they saw when they ran up
their 17 nothing lead in week 12 and
that was not the case but you know peter
when i saw those quotes from bowles in
football morning in america the first
thing i thought of was michael jordan
because that's the thing that i take
away from the last dance documentary
more than anything else in those 10
parts that michael jordan was such a
master at motivation that if he had to
make stuff up he would and these
buccaneers players allowed themselves to
think that no one picked them yeah
people picked them but of course the
weight of it was on the chiefs but there
were people who thought the buccaneers
were going to win the game it was only a
three point margin this wasn't super
bowl 36 with a 14 point
wedge between the rams and the patriots
but you do what you have to do to get
yourself whipped up into a frenzy and
kudos to the buccaneers they did it
well you know the one thing that really
stood out to me from both that
conversation you know with balls and
with listening to some of the defensive
players afterwards
they were really ticked off
because they felt like nobody thought
that they could learn something from
that game in week 12.
and i'll tell you what they learned okay
you do not let
uh tyree kill take over the game
that's that's one thing that i know that
they learned
and they shifted so much defensive focus
to him
and you know mike there was a really
really important play in this game in
the first half
where it was about third and eight and
you know the the kansas city is
struggling to get something going and
patrick mahomes is chasing beautiful
throw on a little out route to jason
kelsey it is right in his hands
and he drops it just as he's being
tackled but that play
i think
basically gave tampa bay
the kind of bravado quite honestly to
essentially be saying
you guys can't take the heat and you saw
how how mouthy that both teams are
mouthy geez tom brady was mouthy uh and
so you saw a mouthy everybody was but
that is when i believe that singular
play
was one of the
very very important plays in the game
because if they convert that and get a
first down and go down and score all of
a sudden you know you're in the second
quarter it's a ball game but
instead it's 21-6 at the half
and it doesn't feel like it's a ball
game anymore
shireen williams made an excellent point
earlier this week on pft pm
if they don't play that game in week 12
if the buccaneers don't have the
opportunity to get blown off the field
early by tyreek hill and patrick mahomes
that's what happens in the super bowl
right
you don't learn from that experience
during the regular season you just step
right into the buzz saw and you're down
big
and yeah the final score of the game was
27-24 but you fall behind 17 points the
chiefs on the biggest stage in sports
good luck eliminating that deficit peter
the one difference is that eric fisher
was playing then
uh and he wasn't playing on sunday and
look i i actually think mike remembers
on the at left tackle played okay he
really actually played okay it was
andrew wiley on the right tackle who
just killed him
he killed the chiefs and and i i you
know the one thing
look we we're gonna spend maybe one
minute of this whole show talking about
kansas city
but
it will it really surprises me that they
weren't able to do anything in a 30
minute half time to say hey listen let's
let's do something radical let's put a
sixth offensive lineman in the game
let's put let's you know let's do
something different and they really
didn't patrick mahomes was chased all
over the field in the second half just
like the first
and that is a question that i think that
andy reid eric b enemy that staff
will probably struggle with
um if they haven't already when they put
the the tape of this game on you know
not really helping out on the right side
more than they did
five-man protection 92 percent of the
time in the game for the kansas city
chiefs and patrick mahomes one of the
most amazing stats coming out of that
game 497 yards running around behind the
line of scrimmage before he threw the
ball or was sacked second only to week 5
when he ran around 495 yards against the
raiders another game that the kansas
city chiefs lost and mahomes obviously
running around on that toe that has
since been surgically repaired which
tells you i don't care what he says
after the game
it was a factor it was an issue that toe
was bothering him and he had to put a
lot of work on top of that toe and make
that toe even worse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports